I've been on your ADK complete, so ADK complete is a vitamin A, vitamin D, vitamin K.
I think there's some vitamin E in it too for a few months. It's all the fat soluble vitamins.
As I was unable to get my vitamin D level up on another brand in the last two months, it has gone
from 30 to 36, which is a big rise, with one pill a day. So one pill a day of the ADK complete is 5,000.
I use vitamin D. I can't remember how much of the other supplements. The other vitamins
it has in it, but should I double my dose or stay on the course? I would double the dose of that.
Sometimes people need to be up 10, even 20,000. I use a vitamin D to get their vitamin D levels up,
which brings up another question, why would a person have difficulty getting their vitamin D levels up?
It can be multiple different reasons. It can be
absorption issues. If you have a history of gallbladder issues, that can be
you can have difficulty in absorbing your fat soluble vitamins. You can have a damaged gut
causing issues in absorption of fat soluble nutrients. Probably the most common reason why a person
has a sluggish ability to get their vitamin D levels up is that they have
defects in their vitamin D receptor genes. So there are specific genes that help you absorb and
utilize vitamin D. If you have a lot of defects in those genes, it can be more difficult to
use. You just need to take more vitamin D.